[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight National Security
Advisor John Bolton got fired this
morning as you no doubt have heard it's
a major personnel change but it's more
than that it is great news for America
especially for the large number of young
people who would have been killed in
pointless wars if bolt had stayed on the
job they may not be celebrating tonight
but they should be international oil
prices by the way on the international
market dropped immediately on the news
investors knew for certain that Bolton
planned on launching yet another Middle
Eastern conflict that would inevitably
spike energy prices no doubt some energy
speculators were disappointed to see
bolt and go certainly many people in
Washington were disappointed Senator
Chris Murphy who's a Democrat from
Connecticut progressive one at that
tweeted that he was quote legitimately
shaken to see John Bolton leave the
White House Samantha power you remember
her she's the Obama official primarily
responsible among other things for the
historically catastrophic destruction of
Libya the move that flooded Europe with
refugees that official Samantha power
told reporters today that the firing was
a very troubling sign believe it or not
a number of Republicans made similar
noises senator Mitt Romney himself
declared that he was quote very very
unhappy that Bolton was leaving Romney
went on to describe the outgoing
national security adviser as quote a
brilliant man with decades of experience
in foreign policy Romney didn't say much
about this experience wasn't specific
about it why probably because none of
Bolton's experience in the end helped
America Romney's right Bouldin has in
facts but on the scene for decades all
of us are suffering the consequences of
it but whatever details like that make
no difference at all in Washington in
Washington nobody cares what kind of job
you did only that you did the job nobody
there learns from mistakes because
mistakes are never even acknowledged
ever John Bolton himself took this form
of selective amnesia to an art form
watch him perform it on this show so
you've you've called for regime change
in Iraq Libya Iran and Syria in the
first two countries we've had regime
change and obviously it's been I'd say
disaster I think now no I don't agree
with that and let me let me don't think
it's been a disaster no I think you need
to understand yeah is that life is
complicated the Middle East and when you
say well the overthrow of Saddam Hussein
was a mistake is simplest I would argue
that I'm the one who understands no
complicated is but just my view it's
it's your long experience in foreign
policy no better record than yours I
would say did you catch that rather than
justify or even explain his own record
Bolden said brags that he spent a lot of
time on the job if you're wondering why
so many progressives are mourning
Bolton's firing tonight it's because
Bolton himself fundamentally was a man
of the left there was not a human
problem John Bolton wasn't totally
convinced could be solved with the brute
force of government that's an assumption
of the left not the right don't the
mustache fool you John Bolton was one of
the most progressive people in the Trump
administration and by the way naturally
once he was descanse there Bolton
promoted Obama loyalists within the
National Security Council that shouldn't
surprise you either from the very first
day John Bolton operated as it infect a
fifth column within the Trump White
House we warned about him frequently on
this show when the president calls for
peace with a heavily armed nuclear power
that is considered treason but when the
National Security Advisor calls for yet
another pointless war
that's just elite consensus and it's
fine a lifelong neocon Bolton repeatedly
has called for toppling the Iranian
government again and again though
tellingly he's never suggested what
might replace the Iranian government
once it's toppled to this day max boot
takes a paycheck from the Washington
Post Bill Kristol appears on MSNBC John
Bolton is this country's national
security adviser there were no
consequences to their foolishness and
their dishonesty none yes mr. president
John Bolton does want to get you into a
war it's all he wants it's what he
dreams about many Wars if possible and
if you're not careful he'll do it in
between administration jobs are always
cushy think-tank posts paid speaking
gigs cable news contracts war may be a
disaster for America but for John Bolton
and his
felony Oh cons it is always good
business we invited John Bolton on the
show tonight he did not respond to the
invitation which is a shame but he's
always welcome here that's a sincere
invitation but in some ways the story
isn't simply about John Bolton it's
about the countless John Bolton's who
currently staff the federal bureaucracy
deeply mediocre lifers drunk on hubris
protected by bullet proof job security
they're more likely to die on the job
than be fired and they know it as a
group these people have done an awful
lot to make this country poorer and
sadder and more divided the actual john
bolton is gone likely forever question
tonight is will he be replaced by
another john bolton just like him and
unfortunately there are signs that
that's possible in fact in washington
it's always possible change is not
always for the better don't lie to
yourself apparently on the short list
tonight to replace Bouldin is the
president's Special Representative for
Iran
Brian hook hook may be a good person
he's also an unapologetic neocon sources
say he is undisguised contempt for
Donald Trump as John Bolton did and he
particularly dislikes the president's
nationalist foreign policy which was one
of the reasons people voted for Donald
Trump in 2016 one administration
official recalls hook announcing that
quote I think the president is reckless
and doesn't understand policy another
source heard him directly say something
very similar to foreign officials at a
conference abroad a choice like that and
hook by the way is not the only one not
even close a choice like that is really
no choice at all it's more john bolton
with the same predictable disastrous
results at least mitt romney and the
energy speculators will be happy but the
country won't be served